so we got a lot what's been going on
well okay you want to start with my new
segment I like to call Hot Gas
please don't call it hot guys okay fine
I like the name thank you hot Goss spill
the tea time with Royce is what I'm
calling this segment let's call this
segment we were [__] right since day
one again well that's just her Show Bud
what was it in 30 Rock when you
continually being right it's called
reaganing We're Reagan right now we're
reaganing right now at the end of it we
pan machine guns but right now we're
pretty cool okay uh not for us though on
a weekend we get machine guns
um
do you want to start with this
the Canadian psychopath by the way this
is The Daily Beast so but I know a lot
of you guys are gonna go all right but
The Daily Beast this is in the New York
Post this is The Daily Beast reporting
on the New York's post so the New York
Post actually is uh uh after this guy
too uh Stephen Crowder repeatedly
exposed genitals to employees that staff
was claim oh no
uh
Stephen
um right wing podcaster Stephen Crowder
has a long run and uh his long-runner
abusive company the New York Post
reported on Tuesday days after an
explosive video appeared to show him
emotionally abusing his ex-wife
according to 10.
but we were wrong about this guy we
didn't yeah I thought it was only three
what did we know I thought it was only
three people that were mad at him he
underestimated that 10 former employees
who spoke to the post Crowder regularly
engaged in unhinged High rates which
we've seen that four subordinates to
wash his dirty laundry wait a second
didn't somebody say the stuff in that
video we have wasn't true it wasn't true
remember when they said it wasn't true I
heard they said that we were making it
up they were cool okay wait till the
potato stuff comes out
um we can't wait to the potato expose
the potato thing is real I don't know
why you guys don't believe it the
Washington Times is dropping the potato
stuff because he gave out the fight they
gave out the Crowder files to different
people like Elon so the Washington Post
will be like the Crowder files part two
so Stephen likes a potato
because if the potato stuff isn't true
the genital stuff isn't true
feed Steven's dog tell the kid
um feed Steven's dog bro do you know how
many times in the last like a couple
days now when I'm doing something around
the house
I'll just finish doing dishes or
something I can't stop myself from going
you are smart yeah I should change my
mind but just every if I finish a load
of laundry I'm like you are smart change
my mind
Marie and I have been Marie and I have
been doing it to each other like all the
time now and the problem is we you
forget that you you forget that it's our
joke but in public I look like a maniac
yeah you guys are like very well very
passive aggressive
people are like um
okay
um according to former employees who
spoke to the post Crowder regularly uh
engaged in unhinged higher rates for
subordinates to watch his dirty laundry
and even exposes genitals to co-workers
six of the sources claim they first hand
witnessed Crowder exposing himself he
climbed over and dropped his junk on the
top of Jared's shoulder not gay Jared
shoulder One X staffer said of an
incident involving ex-producer Jared
Monroe whom Crowder called not gay Jared
I wanted to see what the specifics were
before we were that shocked because look
you've been around
goofy [__] comedians podcast like
you've you know when you were doing
hippo juice John you got like you've
never like Pete guys have never growing
up like [__] around and be like hey have
your ball you have your balls out and be
like hey is there gum on my pants
that kind of [__] I mean guys do that
kind of [__] in a guy setting so I
always wanted to see but once you touch
somebody with your dick like that that
yeah that's an [__] that's not even
that but but let me let me we don't I
don't can I use it yeah what you're
saying if you're right if if Comics or a
podcasters are [__] around and joking
and doing that I wouldn't care but
here's the difference
he was your boss well you're a boss and
not only their boss because that doesn't
even bother me because you could be the
cool boss but he wasn't a cool boss he
was a demanding [__] who also wanted
you to be cool guy that was fun he was
just like psychopath that was rubbing
right that's my point it's not like you
know like buddies that you know Joker
hey cup check or whatever this was like
I'm going to break you make you do my
laundry take my [__] dog I'm a
screamer you make you shot an NDA
imagine that that I also want to goof
around with you no I Just Want to Have
Fun fired no I'm saying it's Crowder
he's like I want you to do all this
slave work and I just also want to goof
around anyway and one of the boys he was
never getting he probably never got
invited to the bar when everybody went
out God no and and and the thing is with
him is like it's it's it's different to
go buddies joking around and you know
you think your [__] out we're joking
around but it's another thing to go hey
I'm gonna take my [__] out sign of Sandy
and don't tell anyone I showed you my
[__] yeah that's getting that's weird
psycho man and again I gotta reiterate
the the you actually played it on a show
you touched another man with it I mean
again that's beyond funny just trying to
fight
me with your dick and you know what I
mean you're gonna get [__] hit
another former employee noted that
Crowder's lewd Behavior was a power play
and if your man like something uh
somebody who might be borderline
Psychopathic would do right right
somebody would say Canadian also uh
uh it's uh he said was a power play and
if your manager at Red Lobster did this
it would be national news which is true
while Crowder and Lottery Crowder
partner Gerald Monroe uh Morgan Sergeant
Morgan didn't respond to the post the
pair jokingly brushed off the claim in
Tuesday's edition of the podcast well I
have that oh we got a video yes we do
by the way can I just say something I
have not oh Jesus now are you wearing
the Jesus one yeah yeah yeah yeah oh
that's a nice little troll because you
know Jesus put his [__] on a pot John
take that off Stephen uh no I I gotta
say because I haven't even seen this
video yet but I can already predict
what's gonna happen hmm he's going to
Triple down and I oh yeah I
of this story arc are you saying you
welcome it I am I need daily Crowder
Double Downs if I can get that injected
into my veins daily I will be oh
got anybody at Rumble maybe regret
sending him that plaque could you move
it they're like could you move it a
little bit to the left hey here's what
we asked if you move it where your
sparkling water is or by your tea here's
the only thing that we asked when we
finished when we finish and the rest
every because we were we were we were
one of the first people doing again like
normal we were the first people that we
saw this we went after years after years
after everyone [__] going after us we
called this [__] dude from day one
all right
from the jump as the kids would say
um the only thing I want I don't want
anything anything other than when we
finally get our plaque I wanted to be
Stevens and I want his name carved out
and ours put in that's it that's all I
want I want nothing else but that
um here's his response to totally normal
thing guy okay all right and that now
there's this newspaper article out this
morning where
um it says quote Crowder was known to
expose his half asian lawyer
it says quote Crowder was known to
expose his genitals to stuff yeah we'll
do yes just wait
I mean that did happen what are you
talking about the Terminator 2 sketch no
but he's downplaying it because he was
naked in sketches at the time he only
had five employees and they were all
male well yeah I know but is that true
it's fine hey guys there's five
employees it was all male yeah I could
rub my dick on any mail employee I want
that's fine because those are that's
that's how lawsuits work you go it was a
guy okay got it that's because remember
the nudies it wasn't one of these dumb
broads but the problem is it was all
guys but one of them was probably a gay
guy you so I mean yeah there's a
difference yeah
uh through the corn fields where we had
to run naked together no it was you
putting your genitals on someone's
shoulders [__] Maniac Hey Hey Stephen
I know you're trying to filter the
information so that your audience goes
oh he acknowledged it and they don't
look into it any further yeah but it's
in the post buddy yeah that's not a
left-wing rag that's a good point and
the allegations are far more serious the
more you play this get the more you kick
around in this [__] quicksand the
worse this is gonna get dude I don't
feel naked in that one yeah we were
naked in that one too that's a good one
it was the night though was it gay
Captain this is shitty though because
his defenses yeah I wrote a bunch of
sketches where my dick was flopping
around in front of employees
and then the best part is bro all the
skits weren't funny and they were crazy
they also sucked yeah they were so
everything about it was so you took your
dick out to make what a shitty clip of
what Bernie's another Bernie Sanders
video say what you want about Harvey
Weinstein and Kevin Spacey but they made
some bangers you know what I mean like
they at least at least they made some
art that stands up all of your
s on YouTube Why was there any need for
anyone to be nude at any point
that's a good point you don't actually
have to be naked because it's it was on
YouTube because it's because it turns me
on oh and I like to feel powerful okay
America because what happened is this
one here we go okay okay
since he didn't fit so we just had to
make it a nosy and there was no
um well now that they're imagining he
was funny he's not here we have to run
things differently this isn't like the
Terminator clip well I know it's not
like the Terminator clip do we have so
this by the way
well not really not necessarily yes it's
a they pre-plan this but this did happen
live on the show if that makes sense but
they practice a sketch yeah yeah they're
doing they're doing a sketch right right
so the allegations came out that you
were putting your genitals on male and
employees number one making you gay
number two
making you an abusive boss and number
three it's again it's one thing to put
your [__] junk on someone's shoulder
but then they make them sign an NDA like
you're [__] that's crazy well yeah
but there's do we have the Terminator
yeah okay
also you could tell with that kind of
behavior he didn't have any black
employees
not any real black employees
maybe quarterback but not full black
yeah go put your sh go go put your dick
on her shoulders and black dude hey you
know what put your dick on it shows one
of the Hodge twins see how see what
happens
that's come with me if you want to learn
look and that's notice he the video he
cut it from up here because he was still
self-conscious about his chest Circle
there was no need to be naked again
right okay
of course many people saw my balls well
yeah but as gone because annuities
wouldn't fit you could you clue it yeah
right yeah yeah but you put your penis
on someone's shoe yeah we were talking
more about the the allegation that
several employees have corroborated that
you exposed to genitals not during a
sketch and then placed them on the
shoulder of your subordinate yeah
a large posterior yes exactly and there
were also times where we played the spot
the ball game yeah well uh we need to
stay on topic as well okay
continuing by the way can I can I point
out something um
you can feel it right
oh yeah oh it's dark it is it is it is
like this is nobody's laughing nobody's
happy to be there everyone's nervous
everyone's on eggshells it this is so
much fun I need more of this it's like
this every day it reminds me it was the
whole show like this I would imagine the
whole show was like this it had to feel
like a [__] wake this is just for
nerds but this is like that episode of
Voyager when they got trapped in that
nebula where there's no way they're
gonna they're gonna die but they kept
doing their job and they kept doing
their Aura and kept doing it and you
keep doing your job and it doesn't
matter we're all gonna die you keep
doing your job that's what this is this
is a this is a a ship that's that you
know it has no this is like a one-way
suicide mission and you're still doing
your job still eating your MRA you're
still doing your [__] uh your PT in
the morning yeah still going for a run
yeah like you're gonna die
Riley said quote govern Me Harder daddy
Riley oh
[Music]
this does feel like nobody wants to be
around you Stephen you're a phony Steven
you are everything we said you were and
honestly worse than we even said you
were he you have been I can I say thank
you Stephen because very not very often
are me and Royce uh you know not often
do we undershoot it but you [__] you
have been beyond anything we could have
even dreamed yeah I mean it's it's crazy
that that that this is like because I
thought it was a couple but 10 people
that's the part that when I read that
this morning I was like 10 people that
bad uh I think I wouldn't get to the
high school your mic isn't really
working all that well um
hold on
oh you say that to me but hold on oh
we're gonna do a bit yeah let me yeah
it's right there
is that your testicle yeah
okay can I take the weird ball thing out
of it and everything can I just judge
this on a comedic level can we judge
this on a bit in the comedic level
it's really funny I know
yeah
this this is one of the [__] least
funniest things he's ever done and I've
watched all his music parodies not only
that right but this feels like um
remember like 20 years ago remember when
the first
R Kelly allegations came out the P ones
you mean yeah yeah the video with the
average girl yeah which was weird how
many places that was hosted for so long
this was like
back then when he decided his first hit
single should be ignition
and that is next Hit album should be
called Chocolate Factory yes
it just felt a little tone deaf at the
time which at least in R Kelly's defense
unlike Crowder's comedy the Ignition
Remix wasn't bad it's a remix
cotton fresh out the kitchen I [__] you
not bro I was like 1920 when that song
came out I was singing along to that
song in the car it almost ended a
relationship I was in all right this is
the chick I was with was so disgusted
with R Kelly but I was like bounce
bounce bounce bounce bounce and she's
like and she's like this is disgusting
turn it off and I'm like this song I
look I know and then I know the guys
what do you think about that and he goes
it's like I was literally I knew it was
one of those songs we all knew all the
words to within three lessons sorry no
you're right I get it
he showed his balls
[Music]
that was really funny so I just sent you
the link to this full episode all right
skipped it two minutes in is when the
show starts and look how he frames this
entire episode
right out of the [__] gate wait a
second why is this whole episode on
YouTube if he's a rumble guy oh he's
been putting them all up he streams live
from oh oh I know oh yeah what is it two
minutes yeah two minutes okay
I'm sorry I should have time stamped it
hey uh Hey really quickly let's go to
CNN oh look they're covering absolutely
nothing and so can I ask what did they
pay him for to come over here
I think he does his second hour second
hours on Rumble that's fair that makes
sense that actually makes sense I mean
to be honest with you Marsh technically
we could do that too if we wanted to I
mean yeah they that's all they wanted
but that intro was foreshadowing look
today is and I know sometimes it's tough
because it is there's always like a
trend that everyone wants to let's talk
but this trend is what you're on
trending this trending but the more
important issue today we'll be talking
about is the agreed upon lie the agreed
upon lie oh we're gaslighting
wait wait for it he's so he's gonna talk
about something by the way guys totally
unrelated to my situation but today
we're going to talk about lies and
deception and how not everything you see
you should believe it's like a pastor
it's like it's it's it's like a pastor
who gets caught cheating doing his next
sermon this is what you're doing Crowder
buddy I [__] told you I told you
you'd love it
you know how I get with certain people
where I blast straight through hating
them and back to the other side I love
them again I absolutely love Stephen
Crowder this guy is gonna he's he's
provided so much so much joy for us all
right here we go
sometimes everything you know is a lie
[Laughter]
thank you
oh
ah
oh I got to get out of my lungs it's
like at the bottom oh
is it Crowder
wait wait for it though I love it that's
not even it I love him no no okay okay
here we go here we go here we go
and what we are dealing with right now
is the UVA race hoax right the hoaxer is
Diana Bryant who ruined someone's life a
woman uh Morgan bettinger for years and
by the way some people's lives are
ruined for years after the fact you may
not remember the name of Darren Wilson
hey what was the name of the man from
mattress girl
verifiably false right do you remember
those names comment below
comment below if you remember the names
we remember the name of the story and
then once there's a verdict I wonder if
anybody below
so many attack
yeah let's check if anybody commented
the names
oh my God
I'm sure Stephen is boiling with rage at
his own fans right now everything is a
lie is a very appropriate title
let's say a ruling that takes place in
actual Court oh yeah he's doing the
ruling in court stuff he is making he is
doing the he's pivoting into personal
[__] to light he's spiraling even harder
he's spiraling even harder and I love it
this is happening this is amazing this
is [__] amazing not right now with
other people in the media episode's
title is literally everything is a lie
bro how long before he's like full of
Owen
about me
I
Jared
I should probably point this out
um
my birthday is in nine no 11 days
and I just want to say I have two radio
shows thank you Ronnie baby I got two
Raiders and I just want to say
thanks Jesus you know not every year I
don't usually always get something from
the universe for my birthday oh God but
thanks Jesus or whoever's doing it this
is awesome uh there's a little bit more
so uh
uh six words about the video the video
of Carter baby
there's the clip oh no that was it no I
think that's pretty much it that was
pretty much the thing so I will also say
this and I I don't know here this here's
I'm just gonna read something I will
give no context
other than the thing that I'm about to
read and that is
the stories have just begun
oh yeah this ain't over oh no it's this
is we're at the very beginning of this
Arc that's where we are we're I I've
even said that on nightwave listen it
this is you gotta understand because
you're gonna have people out there that
go
um you know that this is a [__] you
can't trust the people that are putting
the stuff out because you know they're
all out to attack them yeah and he's not
a bad person listen Crowder being a bad
person
and all of this stuff being true and it
also being a coordinated attack don't
need to be mutually exclusive things a
lot of the people this shit's coming
from are just sleazy [__] that
are out for his blood too I get it but
it's just gonna be fun watching him burn
himself to the ground he's going to keep
dousing himself in gasoline and it's
really funny to watch well A wise man
once said a toad or so a [__] toe
herself oh yeah this is going to be
dripping and dropping
oh there's more hey by the way guys I
want more videos man I think you're
going to find out that a lot of stuff
everything in that training video is
true slowly but you will